billion of a penny or a tenth of a penny
or something. Um it puts a hard cap
something that a human wouldn't even
care about. Like it cost me a penny to
to retweet this. I wouldn't care.
Um
that's a hard cap though on bots doing
the activity and generating fake volume.
Because while it would cost me nothing
to I mean it cost me something but it'd
be inconsequential to me if it cost me
like you know half a yen to to retweet
something. If you had a bot farm doing
that, that would run you tens of
thousands every hour. You're not going
to do that.
So it puts a hard cap on the garbage.
And
because content is essential well
especially while subsidized it's free
at the cost of an economic hangover that
we're going to hit later and it's going
to suck. But that's later.
At the moment it's essentially free to
abuse all the free compute that's being
or free all the subsidized compute
that's out there uh and generate just
reams and reams and reams of trash. Less
than 5% of blogs today actually write
their own stuff anymore. And it's
because it's just already that quickly
been just it's all slop. So the
the problem that we have is not getting
information. In the past that was the
model. We have to suck all the
information we're going to hold it all.
Big data is the whole thing. Now big
data sucks. Now you have to look for
focused meaning.
And focused the search for meaning
online is all about curation. And the
best curation filters are cost signals.
And
you mentioned Milton Friedman.
Everything goes back to having a costly
signal for something. And this actually
gets into a couple of other people aside
from Friedman but um
the uh
you having a costly signal even a tiny
cost even a fractional cost for
something um rules out automated
engagement uh and and fake engagement
farming. Engagement farming is crafted
to get bot attention. Bot attention
begets more bot attention. The bots
advertise to each other. They now look
like algorithmically like high high
value users. Now they go swarm some
content and it looks like it's popular.
That whole model falls apart and you get
back to organic content actually being
the important stuff if it costs even a
tiny bit. Because you can't if every
email cost one penny, there would be
like no spam.